so you're gonna be a rock star what do
you think
[Music]
guys I mean you just redefined really
partying like a rock star like you look
like so much fun in this movie I mean
just talk to me about that because
obviously you're recreating these
legends who are still living how fun was
it to do that I think we created some
more legends down there no it was so fun
no we got to New Orleans and it was
Mardi Gras was happening there's no
better way for us all to get together
and some Patrick's Day as well yeah we
had soup yeah so we just thought that
what we even started yet filming this is
our meeting yeah and then we had lots of
time to play together like to literally
play in band camp as cool as it was very
good what we had told me and Nicky came
down and and helped me with the bass and
you were the drums and you know it was
great fun a new band is gonna be
something nobody's ever seen before we
had these guys on set who are obviously
they live through this was there any
advice that they gave you guys living in
I mean going into this one set the
coolest part was when Tommy would be
behind a screen dude it was just like
that yeah like we did the intro scene
where it was the Motley Crue house which
shows all four of us in this element and
I guess like I guess it was spot-on with
the house and how excited he was they
were so excited when they little props
and the costumes this this ear is so
easy to make look phony or fake and the
wigs and they they really put the time
and the money and energy and making it
perfect and exactly right so I think the
band were well they were so excited by
that they got back together inside of
recording more music so that was cool
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm glad that they gave their you know
seal of approval to you guys but I do
want to talk about you running around
basically in a noon he asked to be in
the bomber the cover was just rolling
for some reason they're just going oh my
gosh no but I mean obviously never we
have that really happened with Tommy but
did he all that he said to you is pretty
much like oh that's exactly how it was
or did he let you improv in any areas
yeah yes it really was like that I mean
I want to point out that specific scene
you're talking about where I'm running
in the speed out to the hallway it's
funny so Mick talked to me yesterday
about he goes uh the guitars he goes you
know I got arrested for that yeah that's
so in real life I guess they blame Mick
that scene happens in real life where
though they set the fire in the hotel
room they're running for cop and they
blamed Mick he just came out it was like
some job in long hair
individually what was the most
challenging scene that you guys had to
film I feel like I may know yours as
Nikki you told by the herald there's
some color of times a dark room in a
kind of very dark place and I've lost
quite a little weight for it because I
was drinking like Bo broth without the
noodles but I hated that time period
dude he was angry right so I was get I
was very hungry and they were too you
know it was hard
I was actually eat salad leaves at lunch
and brought the Naya and coffee in the
morning about we all we all couldn't
wait for him to start stuff in pizza
back as soon as we film that I was like
I was like cookie beats milkshake but no
beer that was that she challenged and
dropping away and getting into that
headspace it's always you know Nikki has
this book called the heroine Diaries and
he kind of chronic he chronicles what
it's like to be addicted to heroin and
he's been you know he has really
suffered with terrible addiction in his
life and amazingly come through that now
a you know great advocate against opioid
addiction and so that was it was that
was a heavy part of this this filming
process but they've been having this in
the works for about 18 years now why was
this a good time to bring this to biopic
out and it was a about time to celebrate
the 80s in the museum and the motley
crew so how many albums are over a
hundred years something million albums
so there's millions and millions of fans
anyway to see this they know the story
inside now and they've been waiting to
see it for very long time so you wanted
to live that movie for them and for the
music as well
Bali's brew here all week
[Applause]